Matthew is in Atlanta hi Matthew welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show better than I
deserve what's up $92,000 in bed um I'm
trying I can't really get started on the
baby steps I'm seeing if you can help me
out why do you think you can't get
started I just don't have the additional
income Howard out of town and so my
budget changes all the time and
sometimes we get paid for them then they
finally don't get paper dim so it's
really hard for me to I want to get a
part-time job but then I can't find
anything doesn't only have one location
for a couple weeks at the time and I'm
just I'm struggling I can't really
figure out what the big shots are you
single
Tom maybe okay and what is the ninety
three thousand and death come along
that's ninety eight hundred feet long
there's eleven thousand seventy or
eleven thousand seven hundred and forty
eight thousand and all day long for
twenty thirty thousand then what's your
income
I'm personally like forty five forty six
thousand my wife in eight eleven and
seven thousand so total fifty six fifty
felonies okay you got a car you can't
afford for one thing now twenty three
thousand dollar car does not fit in this
equation that you gave me that's one of
your problems so what I would do is jump
on have you tried the every dollar
budget okay so the system will the
system works like this man you got fifty
seven thousand dollars coming in you
look at what your monthly income is
going to be for the upcoming month you
can estimate that pretty close and you
might be a little off because you may or
may not get the per diem all these other
things could pop in or out but you're
gonna be pretty close to what your
take-home pay is going to be for the
upcoming month then of the month getting
ready to start December in our case
today
and so then you list out what are you
going to do with that and you give every
one of those dollar
an assignment taking care of food
shelter clothing transportation and
utilities before you do anything else
the basics of life right
once we've got food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities taken care
of then and that's your car payment your
house payment your lights and water you
got money set aside for food then we
begin to work on you know the baby steps
as soon as we can find any other room in
the budget but you've got room in this
budget there there this is doable but
you do have a car you can't afford and
so part of what you're looking at is
you're going to end up selling this car
in order to get ahead because the
$23,000 car in a household that makes
fifty thousand bucks is too much car
when you have more than 50% of your
household income tied up in things with
wheels and motors that are going down in
value it's very difficult mathematically
to get ahead and build wealth like
almost impossible and so this car is
what's killing you here that's one of
the things that's got you stuck and so
I'm moving out of that and I'm gonna get
on a detailed written plan I think you
can do this but now I think you and your
wife are gonna have to sit down together
decide that this is important and we're
not doing anything with money except
what's on this page the the budget
you're the boss of it until you get it
done and once you get it done then it's
the boss of you it's going to tell you
what to do because that way you'll know
we can't do that because we have more
important goals like getting out of debt
more important goals like building
wealth more important goals and you
don't need to see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
and so yeah you probably do need some
extra work you may need to look at your
overall career track and go is this
working for me because you're not making
a ton of money considering they're
running you ragged out of town so is
there another direction you can go long
term with a career that's another thing
you could look at here but that I think
you can do this Matthew you keep working
on it you call me back if I can help
more